jean-marie le chevallier le maire front
national de toulon se déclarent
satisfaits de la condamnation des deux
rappeurs françois léotard parle d'
excellente décision le garde des sceaux
jacques toubon déclare respecter la
décision de justice un jugement qui au
contraire scandalise le syndicat de la
magistrature et de très nombreuses
organisations de gauche louis carzou le
haut parleur d'une génération l'image
convient tout à fait aux groupe ntm dont
les performances sonores ou visuelles
ont toujours fait du bruit
tout au long de leurs sept ans
d'existence avec une réputation et un
verbe sulfureux les ntm ont été plus ou
moins accueilli par les grands réseaux
radiophoniques
ainsi chez nrj le titre la fièvre est
passé près de deux cents fois car l'on
considère la virulence du groupe comme
une tradition de la chanson française
les parents landel même si on les
analyse et vous les ai relu avant que
vous veniez je cache pas il faut les
prendre peut-être au deuxième degré on
parle de rêve etc
puis bon ce qui est dit n'est pas
forcément pensé pour autant l'accueil
n'a pas toujours été aussi paternaliste
ainsi la chanson et le clip de ge appuyé
sur la gâchette vont déclencher le refus
de la plupart des radios comme de
l'ensemble des chaînes hertziennes
même les chaînes musicales du câble vont
alors se montrer prudent qu en ne
diffusant les images que quatre fois
pour information une présence désormais
obligée face à des modes dans la musique
dont le seul point commun est la
violence on fait attention à ce qu'on
diffuse parce que on va pas on n'est pas
là pour être le cheval de troie de
de la station la destruction de la
station d'apologie de mesrine au genre
de choses ce soir le problème ntm a
définitivement quitté la seule sphère
des médias musicaux
mais du côté de classe politique à
l'exception du front national l'on
considère quand même que les élus n'ont
pas à contrôler la culture les
dictatures commence toujours par vouloir
contrôler les cultures quant au front
national qui vient de commenter cette
décision de justice
je voudrais lui dire qu'il faut qu'il
balaie devant sa porte
à orange il ya eu des groupes de rock
kurde était l'invité des groupes de rock
violon dont une chanson s'appelle une
valve et je voudrais citer une phrase
cette chanson une balle pour les
sionistes une balle pour les
cosmopolites une balle pour les élus une
balle pour la paix pointe expansion tout
le monde pense à la police bien je crois
qu'il faut que dans une république comme
la nôtre la justice passe ponctuellement
et au moment où on va faire entrer andré
malraux au panthéon samedi prochain je
ne veux pas ne pas me souvenir que des
censeurs de tout poil avait demandé au
ministre de l'époque d'interdire la
pièce de jean genet les paravents qui
mettait en cause les militaires pendant
la guerre d'algérie et andré malraux
leur a répondu avec vigueur
il faut réfléchir à deux fois avant de
jeter la liberté par la fenêtre
malraux avait conclu je choisis la
liberté et je choisis à l'image de
malraux la liberté